هذا هو النمط الجديد لسفينة خفر السواحل اليونانية
على حافة
المياه التركية
، أخبرنا أطقمها أنهم حصلوا للتو على
معلومات حول حادثة دفع
محتملة للمهاجرين واللاجئين على
متن سفينة يونانية تتحرك نحو مياهها الخاصة
إنه يفر الآن نحو
lesbos ، حيث يحشد الأتراك لإنقاذ البحر
مع خطر إضافي من covet 19.
الآن إنه سباق مع الزمن
لقد أودت هذه المياه بالفعل
بالعديد من الأرواح ، حيث اكتشفوا
طوف النجاة بدون محرك ينجرف
خذ الحبل خذ الحبل وأمسك
بالحبل
ولا تدعهم يذهبون
واحدًا تلو الآخر ، فإنهم يخرجون من
أحد عشر شخصًا في المجموع بالكاد قادرين على الوقوف
رطبًا باردًا ومرهقين ، يتجمعون
معًا في الجزء الخلفي من القارب
لأنك لا تريد حقًا معرفة
ما فعلوه بنا
ولا يزالون في حالة صدمة  روا كيف
وصلوا إلى جزيرة ليسبوس اليونانية
قبل يومين ،
لكن السلطات اليونانية ألقت القبض
عليهم ، ويقولون إن ممتلكاتهم
وأموالهم أخذوني من رقبتي وبدأ يضربني.
لقد وضعوا سكينًا على بطن زوجي وصوبوا
مسدسًا على رأس ابني ،
وأجبروا على ركوب قارب وتركوه
في البحر ،
تقول فاطمة إن عائلتها هربت من
لبنان اليائس ، لقد جربوا عبور البحر
خمس مرات في الأشهر الستة الماضية
كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي يصلون فيها إلى
الأراضي اليونانية ،
وقد وثق دعاة حقوق الإنسان في وكالة الأمم المتحدة للاجئين
العديد من
الروايات المماثلة منذ مسيرة
مجموعات المراقبة التي تتهم اليونان بانتهاك
التزامات حقوق الإنسان بطرد
طالبي اللجوء
في بعض الأحيان وتركهم عابرين في البحر لساعات
وفقًا لـ  خفر السواحل التركي
كان هناك ما يقرب من
200 حادثة رد في عام 2020
يقولون إنهم أنقذوا ما يقرب من
6500 رجل وامرأة وطفل يقول أياك من الصومال إنهم
عوملوا مثل
الحيوانات ، كل شخص تحدثنا إليه هنا
يقول
إنهم لا يفعلون ذلك.  لا يريدون تجربة هذه الرحلة مرة أخرى ،
فهم لا يريدون
المحاولة والذهاب عبر اليونان بسبب ما
مروا به ، لقد صُدموا حقًا من
أن هذه
هي الطريقة التي يستخدمها اليورو  تتعامل المؤسسة العامة مع البشر
ردًا على تقارير CNN ،
وتنفي الحكومة اليونانية أنهم
يعيدون المهاجرين واللاجئين
، ويقولون إن السلطات تحرس
الحدود وفقًا لقواعد
القانون الدولي
، ويتهمون تركيا بتسليح
قضية المهاجرين
في وقت كانت فيه الهجرة.  في
قلب عاصفة سياسية في الاتحاد الأوروبي ،
سمعت أن اليونان جزء من الاتحاد الأوروبي ،
أردت الوصول إلى الاتحاد
الأوروبي لألمانيا لتعليم أطفالي
والعيش هناك ، ولكن إذا كانت اليونان تمثل
الاتحاد الأوروبي ،
فأنا لا أريد أيًا من ذلك
من المؤكد أنهم يقولون
إنهم لن يعودوا إلى اليونان
بعد ما مروا به للتو من
عمليات الطرد القسري هذه وعمليات الإعادة التي
يبدو أنها تتحول إلى القاعدة الجديدة ،
ليس فقط لتعريض الفئات الأكثر ضعفاً
للخطر في المياه الغادرة ،
ولكن أيضًا إغراق القيم  أن
أوروبا تدعي أنها ترمز إلى
gemana karachay cnn في شمال
بحر إيجه